[Music]
i'm the first person to both fly in
space
and touch the deepest point in the ocean
[Music]
my missions have taken me over 2 million
feet above sea level
[Applause]
and 35 853 feet below sea level
i've seen things no other human being
has and they've absolutely changed me
in a lot of ways
[Music]
i'm kathy sullivan i'm an oceanographer
and astronaut
my interest in science showed up at very
early age
i really had a lust for adventure and
travel and exploration
my first space flight was in october of
1984
after 15 years as an astronaut i made my
way back to earth to focus on the oceans
i've always thought that it's too bad we
never created a nasa for the deepest
deepest parts of the sea
we know more about our moon and mars
than we do about the deep sea so little
is known about the shape of the bottom
so one of the objectives was mapping the
deep sea floor
[Music]
deep sea submersible dives and space
shuttle flights can be
pretty different
on the space shuttle took us eight and a
half minutes to go from zero miles an
hour to orbital velocity
17 500 miles an hour
it amounts to riding a bomb when you get
into orbit
you're a couple hundred miles above the
earth any direction you look
you can see probably nearly a thousand
miles
you get 16 sunrises and 16 sunsets in
every 24-hour day
you're just stunned by the number of
stars that you can see so
there kind of isn't really an inky black
of space that's anything like the
the inky black of the deep sea
going to the bottom of the ocean
contrast was like the world's
smoothest calmest elevator ride and it
took us
four hours to go from the surface to
nearly 36 000 feet
it is kind of like a magic school bus i
mean you're sitting inside this cozy
little metal sphere
you might be munching a tuna fish
sandwich and yet
outside that sphere pressure's about
1100 times
greater than it is here on the surface
of the earth
it's pitch dark except for what light
you bring with you on the submarine
we could maybe see 30 feet in whatever
direction we were looking at the
viewport
it was like a moonscape or an underwater
desert
it really is in a lot of ways harder to
explore and understand the ocean
i've spent a fair amount of time living
in these complex machines
i think intense experiences deepen the
value that you put on family on home so
i look back at my life
and i see vastly more blessings and
sacrifice
to actually have those experiences and
to deepen our understanding of our
planet and how many ways we depend on
that to me is all blessing
we are all sharing this one home this
one little spaceship earth
we have to look at it as a place that
you cherish in a place you want to
protect
we're on it together and we're
intimately connected
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew bebe and
i'm here in my terrible
home studio that i've made during
quarantine
and i wanted to tell you about our new
podcast called great big story
it's got more surprising and delightful
stories just like this one
so head over to apple podcast to spotify
wherever you get your favorite podcasts
and download
great big story